techniques différentes mais un point
commun tous les artistes présentés sont
franciliens un choix de la société
versaillaise des artistes d'île de
france pour son 154e salon on a mélangé
chaque année on a des gens qui ne sont
pas professionnels et d'autres qui sont
professionnels donc on a fait un choix
en disant que ce qui n'était pas
professionnelle pouvait exposer une
oeuvre et les autres jusqu'à 3 une
quinzaine d'artistes yvelinois a été
sélectionnés dont la sculptrice
guyancourt toiser duc et anne-marie
ponsard peintre basé au vésinet je
travaille sur une année sur un thème qui
m'est venue en revenant de voyage
alors ça c'était en venant d'afrique
j'ai changé les couleurs j'ai changé tas
de choses
j'en ai fait un autre avant qui est
beaucoup plus figurative disons et puis
petit à petit le travail évolue et
devient
plus abstrait sculptures peintures
gravures autour de deux artistes invités
elizabeth hoodless originaire de
versailles travaille le métal de
récupération ses proches du modelage
pour moi voilà je trouve que c'est un
matériau
qui est king et noble alors je travaille
toujours avec du métal de récupération
j'aime le côté
du matériau qui a déjà vécu plus de 60
oeuvres sont rassemblés au coeur du
carré à la farine de versailles
à découvrir jusqu'au 17 novembre